welcome to exploring computing
today's video is introduction to html
creating a web page step by step
now this example web page we're showing
right here
we aren't going to quite get to that
level of sophistication today
but we will very shortly because that's
actually on next week's homework
assignment
for now we're going to start off with
something simpler so in the previous
video we talked about what html was
and we talked a bit about the different
roles of html
what we're going to do now is walk you
through what you need to do in order to
actually create your own html web page
so the first thing we need to do is we
need to get a text editor
now i need to clarify that a text editor
is not the same as a word processor
so something like microsoft word is
designed to create
formatted documents using a process
called what you see is what you get
where when you're editing it you can
actually see what the print page is
going to look like
it turns out this doesn't work that
great with web pages because
what you see is not what you get with a
normal text document you actually have
complete control over
what this printed page is going to look
like you have control over
the device you're going to print it on
you have control over the size of the
page
none of that happens in html you are
creating a web page that will be seen on
many different devices with many
different characteristics so this what
you see is what you get are
as we sometimes refer to computer
science wysiwyg does not work well
for web pages so we want to use a text
editor
and there's a variety of different text
editors that are out there
i'm going to recommend using visual
studio code
you can find it by just googling it i
should clarify that
visual studio code is different from
visual studio they're both products of
microsoft
and they run on macintosh windows and
linux
and they're used by professionals so um
this is a really great
text editor it's used by a lot of
professionals and it's free so
win-win-win but you can use other text
editors sublime and adam are
two other text editors that will run on
any of the different platforms you might
be on and are used by professionals
if you're on the macintosh using text
wrangler or bb edit is totally fine
if you're on the pc if you've got
something like notepad plus plus that's
fine as well
the key point here is you want to use a
text editor
not something that edits rich text
meaning text with
bold and italic and things like that if
your text editor shows content that has
bold and italic in it
that's not the kind of text editor you
want in particular macintosh users
should not
use text edit that's the standard built
in text editor for macintosh text edit
has direct support for rich text
it's possible to use text edit for
creating html
if you know what you're doing but it's a
little confusing on
actually how to do it and we found many
students have trouble with it so we
strongly do not recommend that you use
textedit
so again i recommend microsoft visual
studio code it will run on both macs and
pcs
but there are a variety of other text
editors you can use
make sure it's a text editor and do not
use the standard macintosh text edit
you should also consider turning on file
extensions display
in your operating system computer setup
for consumers don't show file extensions
and so these are things like txt dot
html
dot doc dot pdf these go on the ends of
files and they indicate what type of
file it is
and typically if a computer is set up
for consumers it's going to be hidden
this is going to get a bit confusing
though when we're working on with our
web pages and we're doing programming
so for the next couple months you guys
are going to be doing some programming
work and i do recommend that you turn on
file extensions
and you can see here on my images here
on the left i have the file extensions
on and on the right i have the file
extensions off
even though there are several files that
appear to have the same name
they're actually different because they
have different extensions and so
it is easier telling what's going on
with the file extensions are on i do
recommend you turn them on
i'm not going to go over actually how to
turn them on since it is quite different
from one
operating system to another and i just
recommend you just go ahead and google
it
okay so here's the basic steps we're
going to use to create and edit web
pages
we're going to start with a starter file
so i'm going to provide you with a
starter file i recommend you start with
that
you're going to add your text you're
going to validate it for syntax errors
so this is errors in the tags that we
talked about in the previous lecture
once you complete getting rid of all the
syntax errors then you're going to try
and load it into your web browser you're
going to see if you like what the result
is
and if you like the result great you're
done
or you can continue extending it if you
think there's a problem with how it
appears
you need to go back to step two and edit
your text
revalidate it reload it in the web
browser and so on
so let's go over each of these
individual steps so as i mentioned
i do recommend you start with a starter
file we will providing you with a
starter file
there's no need to memorize all the
structural information that appears in
every html file
if this were a regular quarter we would
actually provide the structural
information for you on
the midterm and the final but since
there's no midterm or final you don't
have to worry about that at all
anyway use the starter file there's no
reason to memorize all this stuff
okay once you have your starter file in
hand
you need to open it up in your text
editor
now the thing about html files is if you
just double click on an html file it's
going to open up in the web browser
it's not going to open it up in the text
editor so you need to
explicitly open up the html file in your
text editor
so there's a variety of ways to do this
probably the most straightforward method
is to go up to the text editor's file
menu
and choose open and go to wherever your
starter file is i
commonly actually just drag the file
over from
the desktop finder desktop if you're on
pc finder if you're on the macintosh
i just drag grab that file icon and just
drag it into the text editor
you're welcome to do it any way you want
just remember if you double click on
that file it's going to open it up in
the web browser which is not what you
want
you want it open up in the text editor
okay so you've got your starter file
you've got in your text editor just go
ahead and edit it and add in some text
and so here's my example here
and i've added it and it looks great now
it turns out that
once you've done that you could just
open up your web browser but we don't
recommend this
we recommend an extra step and this
extra step is actually going to save you
a great number of points over the
quarter on your homework so definitely
take this next step
this next step is validating your html
file
so what a validator is is it's a program
that is designed to look through your
html file
and find any errors on that html file
the thing to keep in mind is web
browsers are not designed to show errors
on a web page if i'm visiting somebody's
web page like let's say i go to the new
york times i go to amazon
if that web page has errors on it and
there are a shocking number of
professional web pages that have what
might be considered errors often they're
there because there's some new extension
that's not
actually technically part of the
language yet that they want to play with
or there's old legacy stuff that
shouldn't really be there anymore but
they leave it in there
but anyway you know if i visit one of
these web pages and there's an error in
it
do i want to know about it no it's not
my web page so
web browsers are designed primarily for
consumers
not for web developers there are ways
that we can turn on
some error messages in the web browser
but
the easiest thing to do is just to use
this validation process
so remember the web browser is not going
to tell you
if there are errors on your web page
it's just going to happily ignore them
now one thing you might be wondering is
if my web page
has supposedly has errors and i can't
actually see them do they matter
and here's the thing different web
browsers will
interpret erroneous code differently
so it could be that the web browser that
you're viewing your errors in
more or less figures it out which is
you're trying to do and your web page
looks perfectly normal in that web
browser but
if we're professionals we need to check
it on a wide range of web browsers we're
not supporting just one web browser
we're supporting many web browsers we
need to support chrome
safari firefox edge and then we need to
support a different number of hardware
platforms so
windows mac os ios android
and then each of these different devices
is going to
potentially display webpage differently
depending on
what version of the operating system i'm
using or what version of the web browser
i'm using and so we were professionals
we would have
rooms of different hardware devices with
different software installed on it so we
could check our web page against
all these different options we're not
going to do that for our class but
by validating your file by making sure
that there are no
errors in your file you are greatly
reducing the chances that your file is
going to appear
differently in one of these web browsers
so definitely validate your file
and we're going to validate your file
and if you have errors in your file when
we validate it you're going to lose
points so
if for no other reason validate your
file because
otherwise you're going to lose homework
points okay so there's a variety of
different ways to validate your file
we're going to use an online service
from the world wide web consortium this
is the
official consortium that's in charge of
web standards
and so you can see the url for it here
on
on the screen and so in the right
this is what the validator service looks
like and
in the middle tab there's something
that's marked file upload
you want to select that that's going to
allow us to upload a file from our
computer
to the world wide web consortiums
validator service where it can check on
their computer and see if there are any
errors
in our file so go ahead and check on
that
after you click on that you'll also see
a series of check boxes i recommend that
you check the box that says
show source that's going to make it a
little bit easier telling what's going
on
one of the nice things about showing the
source is it does show you
where the individual line numbers are
and you can compare that to the error
numbers
but if you're using a good text editor
like visual studio code that will show
you the line numbers as well
anyway key point here is just go to
validator.w3.org notice that's org
this is a non-profit organization and
upload your file there
and check it out so here's what the
results will look like
this is a modified version of the
html file i showed a couple minutes ago
the html file i showed you a couple
minutes ago
doesn't have any errors but um i wanted
to shift some errors so i modified it
and put in a bunch of errors and this is
what it's going to look like when you
have errors
now a couple things about having errors
first of all everybody has errors in
their code
that's particularly going to be true
when we start programming
but it's also going to be true for your
html so you know
if you have errors in your code
congratulations you're human
second you may end up with what appears
to be a lot of errors
don't be intimidated by lots and lots of
errors typically what's going to happen
as soon as there's one or two errors at
somewhere at the beginning of your code
it causes a cascading sequence of
problems for the validator
so you know if you see 35 errors there's
probably only three
probably what happened was those first
couple errors
caused the validator to not understand
what's going on and now it's marking a
bunch of stuff as errors when it's not
actually error so
you know just don't get intimidated if
there's a huge number of errors
take out the first error you know you
can revalidate it then and see how many
errors that
takes out of your list it's likely to
take out more than one error on the list
so you know don't be shocked if there's
a lot of errors that
listed by the validator that doesn't
mean those are actually all
real errors start with the first one on
the list
also the validator will often notice the
error
on the line after the error has occurred
what's happening here is the validator
is looking for a particular thing in the
code
and it's expecting it to occur on the
previous line and it's not until it gets
to the next line when it realizes
hey i didn't see that thing so for
example you know we've talked about how
attribute value pairs the
value should have quotes around it and
so what can happen is
you have a starting quote you forget to
put the ending quote it's looking for
that ending quote it's looking for the
ending quote
it's not until it gets to the next line
when it says hey
i think i should have seen a quote i see
you're starting a new
tag here didn't we need to end the
previous tag and that's where it's going
to mark the error
so often the error will occur on the
line before the line number the
validator actually marks
okay now we've validated our code
we've removed all the errors and you're
you're there's a little
cycle here where you're going to go
ahead and
try to validate you're going to find
some errors you're going to add your
code you're going to revalidate you're
going to find some errors
you're going to change your code and
you're just going to have to cycle
through that until you've removed all
the errors let's say we removed all the
errors
okay now we're going to load it into the
web browser so as i as i mentioned
earlier
web browsers all actually act a little
bit differently
for the web pages we're making this is
unlikely to occur but
it may occur so if we were professionals
we would be testing in a whole bunch of
different web browsers on a whole bunch
of different hardware platforms we're
not going to do that for
our class we want to use one
standardized web browser and so
we're going to use firefox so get the
latest version of firefox
that's what we're going to be grading it
on all right
to open it up again don't double click
it you know
depending on how your computer is set up
there's a variety of different web
browsers
that are probably the standard web
browser you
use for day-to-day browsing and that's
what it's going to open it in
instead start at firefox go to file open
or drag the file into
firefox while it's open and uh just drag
it from
the desktop finder
into the web browser and it will go
ahead and open it up okay
it looks great great we're done or
great and i want to add some more to it
and i want to enhance it
either way there is this continuing
process where
i edit the code i revalidate i load it
into the web browser i see their
problems or if i want to enhance it
and so there's this cycle it's called
the edit debug cycle and this is
something that
programmers actually spend large parts
of their day working on
so it's definitely something you're
going to be doing when you start working
on web pages
all right so that's it for our basics on
how to make some web pages
and you'll get a chance to practice with
this on the next homework assignment
which will be coming out soon
you